what's the computational complexity of
figuring out the shortest path in um
with molecules with language with
mathematical theorems it seems like once
you have the fully constructed Lego
Castle or whatever your favorite Lego
world is figuring out how to get there
from the building basic building blocks
isn't like a is that an empty hard
problem it's a hard problem it's a hard
problem but actually if you look at it
so the best way to look at it for let's
take a molecule so if the molecule has
um 13 bonds first of all take 13 copies
of the molecule just cut all the bonds
so take cut 12 bonds and then you just
put them in order yeah and then that's
how it works so and you keep looking for
Symmetry and re or or copies so you can
then shorten it as you go down and that
becomes comor quite hard um for some
natural product
molecules um it's comes very hard it's
not impossible possible but we're
looking at the bounds on that at the
moment but as the object gets bigger it
becomes really hard and but there that's
the bad news but the good news is there
are shortcuts and we might even be able
to physically measure the complexity
without computationally calculating it
which is kind of insane wait wait how
would you do that well in the case of
molecule um so if you shine light on a
molecule let's take it infrared the the
molecule has each of the bonds absorbs
the infrared differently in what we call
the fingerprint region and so it's a bit
like a um and because it's quantized as
well you have all these discrete kind of
absorbances and my intuition after we
realized we could cut molecules up in
Mass Spec that was the first go at this
we did it with using infrared and the
infrared gave us an even better
correlation assembly index and we used
another technique as well in addition to
infrared called NMR nuclear magnetic
resonance which tells you about the
number of different magnetic
environments in a molecule and that also
worked out so we have three techniques
which each of them independently gives
us the same or tending towards the same
assembly index for molecule that we can
calculate mathematically okay so these
are all methods of mass spectrometry
mass spec you scan a molecule it gives
you data in the form of a Mass Spectrum
and you're saying that uh the data
correlates to the assembly index yeah so
how generalizable is that shortcut first
of all to chemistry and second of all
beyond that CU that seems like a nice
hack and you're extremely knowledgeable
about various aspects of chemistry so
you can say okay it kind of
correlates but you know the whole idea
behind assembly Theory paper and perhaps
why it's so controversial is that it
reaches
bigger it reaches for the bigger general
theory of objects in the universe yeah
I'd say so I'd agree so I've started
assembly theory of emoticons with my lab
believe it or not so we take emojis yeah
pixelate them and work out the assembly
index for emoji yeah and then work out
how many emojis you can make on the path
of emoji so there's the Uber emoji from
which all other Emoji em emojis emerge
yeah and then you can so you can then
take a photograph and by looking at the
shortest path on U by reproducing the
pixels to make the image you want you
can measure that so then you start to be
able to take um spatial data now there's
some problems there what is then the
definition of the object how many pixels
um how do you break it down and so we're
just learning all this right now so how
do you compute the how do you begin to
compute the assembly index of a
graphical like a set of pixels on a 2G
plane that form a thing so you would
first of all determine the resolution so
then how how many what is your XY well
the number on the X and Y plane and then
look at the surface area and then you
take all your emojis and make sure
they're all looked at the same
resolution yes and then we would
basically then um do the exactly the
same thing we would do for cutting the
bonds you'd cut bits out of the Emoji on
and look at the the you'd have a bag of
pixels so um and you would then add
those pixels together to make the
overall emoji wait wait a but like first
of all not every pixel's
I mean this is at the core sort of
machine learning and computer vision not
every pixel is that important and
there's like macro features there's
micro features and all that kind of
stuff exactly what like uh you know the
eyes appear in A lot of them the smile
appears in a lot of them so in the same
way in chemistry we assume the bond is
fundamental what we do in there here is
we assume the resolution that the scale
of which we do it is fundamental and
we're just working that out and that
you're right that will change right
because as you take your lens out a bit
you it will change dramatically but it
but it's just a new way of looking at
not just compression what we do right
now in computer science and data one big
kind of um uh um kind of
misunderstanding as assembly theory is
telling you about how compressed the
object is that's not right it's a how
much information is required on a chain
of
events
all